our friend Cal Ripken is called into the
program and again tonight's two-hour
episode of Gordon Ramsay's 24 hours to
hell and back is about helping out the
folks in Ellicott City in the great
state of Maryland which obviously Cal
has been all about for so many here is
the Baseball Hall of Famer Cal Ripken
here on the Rich Eisen show for a few
minutes how are you Cal yeah sorry I was
a few minutes late I caught the tail end
of what you're talking about what are
you talking about the reaction when
Michael said he had to take a break you
know on the show the other night yeah I
mean there's a lot of conversation about
his um his leadership style and whether
it was it's good or bad Cal and he
because I was trying to figure that out
that's the way I play that's who I am
and if you can't if you don't want to
play that way don't I thought it was it
was an interesting moment I didn't
expect him to get emotional at that
moment so what do you think of that
subject that a matter that's been
bandied about quite a bit lately Cal
about leadership and that that style I
think I've just taken it all in and
trying to formulate my opinion because
it does it does bump around all over the
place I'm in some ways some ways you
know his competitiveness and his uh his
desire his leadership and and I would
say basketball is an intense sport I
mean I didn't play it professionally but
I love to play it and the emotions that
are pulled out of me
you know just playing you know pretty
pretty high level pickup games and those
sorts of things is a different sort of
competitive fever and so I try to relate
to that so I'm learning and listening
and I know that tempers flare on any
teams that when you when you're close by
so his desire to win was evident you
know from all of us but it's interesting
to me that they're examining it so
closely in the interpersonal
relationship so I'm still I'm still log
digesting it so I really don't know if I
have a good opinion yet well I mean it's
you sound conflicted I mean we do have
BJ Armstrong on a program yesterday and
one of Jordans teammates and then also a
competitive
somebody who was standing in his way
later on in his career we had him on
yesterday and he said that Jordan would
never ever and this is what made him a
good a good teammate if not a great
teammate he would never ask of anybody
something that he would not do himself
and you were guy who never missed a game
cow so what was your leadership style
from that point of view well I think the
most powerful form of leadership is by
example
and so he he lived it he did it he cared
about it but again the emotional aspect
of you know sharing the ball moving the
ball around you know the type of offense
the type of defense help defense and all
those kind of things that gear you're
relying on your teammates all the time
in crucial timing situations baseball in
a lot of ways is up to you when you're
at bat you know it's it's your timing
it's your you're figuring out I guess
the only time you're really coordinating
is when you're on defense and turning
double plays and those sorts of things
but it's not nearly the same thing so I
don't know I appreciate the his desire
and I appreciate you know the boisterous
market sometimes you know when you play
a sport when I look at basketball 82
games is like 162 in baseball I mean
it's a long long season a long long
schedule and the hardest part about
playing every single day is your
individual motivation and sometimes that
comes and goes you have to force
yourself you know to maybe kick yourself
in the tail and sometimes you got to
kick some other people in the tail they
got to kick you in the tail
there's just part of being on a team so
it seems like Michael kicked a lot of
people to tail he certainly did Cal
Ripken jr. here on the Rich Eisen show
and I know we have a limited amount of
time here with you so speaking of
kicking people in the tail Gordon Ramsay
does exactly that how do you how did you
get hooked up with him and and what you
did for the good folks in Ellicott City
in in in Maryland after not one but two
massive floods that was such an easy
thing for me is uh you know the two
floods there it devastated the area at
businesses and an effort to come in and
rebuild I thought the concept of the
show was remarkable I'm a Gordon Ramsay
fan
I follow him a little bit I like to cook
so I watch different cooking shows from
time to time so I was familiar with him
it was interesting to me as he was he's
a big guy you know when he came in a
first man and we started talking he's
got a presence about him this doesn't
mess presidents that he brings to the
table in a team team situation and what
he does or in a project like this really
matters to everyone around so he's one
of those leaders that he doesn't have to
demand the attention but he gets it Cal
Ripken jr. here on the Rich Eisen show
again at 8:00 Eastern on Fox tonight
he'll be part of that two-hour episode
about helping the community rebuild in
Ellicott City Maryland so much of a
conversation going on about the 2020
season Cal and obviously you're just
like the rest of us sitting around
waiting to see what can happen we were
talking earlier about the nuts and bolts
of actually having something this season
and how it would work and how clearly
having a clubhouse might be verboten can
you can you have a season without a
clubhouse in Major League Baseball Cal
it would take us back to our amateur day
Yeah right
what are you driving in a car and you go
on up and play and get in your car and
you go home you know all those things
can be worked around and because the
real the real competition starts when
you're facing a pitcher on the mound and
you get in the situations you're trying
to win a game and I think all of the
natural instincts of all the athletes
kick in at such a high level where it's
not that they're they're blocking out
any fan participation all that because
there's nothing like having that element
that that environment that's the
difference in playing in the minor
leagues a lot of times in front of
hardly anybody and then come to the big
leagues you got to make an adjustment to
the to that level and so but I think
everyone will adjust the leadership and
the camaraderie and the talk of baseball
in some ways you know when I go into a
locker room after the game now and it's
not too often you know 10 minutes after
the game everybody's gone you know
they're they go their separate ways
they're they're in and out I know
they're at the ballpark earlier than we
used to be but there used to be a lot of
us that sat around and talked about the
game and tried to learn from the city
and and just kind of get it out of our
system so we can apply you know fresh
new day so I don't know what clubhouse
camaraderie is a to me chemistry and
camaraderie is built out there on the
field and it's built with your successes
in the eighth inning executing a bunt
play holding the guy on throwing a guy
out stealing you know preserving a win
with a double play I think all those
confidences are made mostly out on the
field but it'll be different but I think
everybody will respond to the challenge
that's put before them yeah I'm not
being facetious like literally some
players might have to show up in their
uniforms like they did for Pony baseball
like true love you heard the story about
Brady Anderson when he lived downtown in
Baltimore gofal yeah one at the time
it's just perfectly so he would
rollerblade over in his uniform with
sweats over top anyway anyways go down
the loading dock Tunnel come out the
groundskeeping side or whatever others
roller blades on kick him off with
velcro spikes on him he could hit that
way he could have maximized time at home
but he made a grand entrance to stretch
mean quite a few times so that's so I
mean why not if you could do that you
know and was that his 50 home run season
count I think you know Brady Brady was
always doing something that involved you
know physical skill or his obsession
with hockey at one point ice hockey and
the offseason tennis he'd come back
standing on a physio ball and squatting
two big plates you know just to show
that he what he worked on during the
offseason so I would imagine that might
have been in his 50-ohm run year because
it was a free spirit anyway I bet but I
think in that year uh he could eat
probably could've done anything and we
were said that was great
can appreciate the time man let's let's
do this again
you know maybe in a couple weeks down
the road just catch up and just go down
a little bit more memory lane because as
you know folks are nostalgic for for the
days of your or just for people like
yourself telling stories and I'd love to
I'd love to avail myself of that if
you're if you're willing I'd love to I
got on Twitter here recently and I've
been I was hesitant and I've been
enjoying being able to communicate some
of the old stories and some of the times
that have happened
I'm pleasantly surprised I thought you
had to be extroverted to have some sort
of success in that but I like the
platform to being able to communicate
okay on many levels
yes do you know what you sound like
talent you sound like you're new to
Twitter when you say stuff like that new
can't be Cal Ripken jr. trolls there
just can't be I hope that oh my gosh
don't tell me what a troll is right now
I can kind of imagine what now let's
talk off fair
let's talk offline well we'll connect
and I look forward to the next time we
could do it on this show you got that at
Cal Ripken jr. on Twitter the Millennial
cow out there tweeting hey you watched
all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here